their interventions to me in statements
and from other comments that they have
been making wish to ensure that we don't
leave the European Union now that may be
various way than people way people wish
to do that but that I think that this is
we're at a point where we have
negotiated a deal that people thought we
would never be able to negotiate we have
negotiated a good deal for the United
Kingdom we have and there is a clear
choice I think for members of parliament
it's important that we honor the vote of
the referendum it's important that we
deliver on brexit this is a deal that
does that it delivers on what people
voted for but it also ensures that we
can protect jobs protect people's
livelihoods protect our Union and
protect our security now we do
understand this point but would you
accept that the only way in which there
could be no great suit at all which is
one of the possibilities you have told
the House of Commons might come to pass
would be through another vote of the
people is that the only way you think no
bricks it could happen there's there's
ways in which some members of house want
to delay brexit breaks it in as far as
I'm concerned takes place on the 29th of
March 2019 you will have heard from
individuals within the house who asked
about extending article 50 that there
are people who think the way to avoid
brexit on 29th of March is to extend
article 50 what I'm saying is that
actually what people need to focus on
and what I hope people want to focus on
what is the choice before us of actually
ensuring that we deliver on the vote of
the British people but doing it in a way
that protects jobs protects our security
so extending article 50 could result in
no breaks it at all is that what you're
saying what I'm saying is that what I am
saying is that if you listen to members
of the House of Commons
you will hear a variety of views as to
what should be happening on this issue
there are those there are those who
would be happy to leave without a deal
there are those who wish to leave with a
deal there are those who don't want to
leave at all
and within that there are people who
think that perhaps a route is a second
referee
I think that is an attempt to frustrate
brexit there are those who talk about
extending article 50 I think that is an
attempt to frustrate brexit I'm focused
on delivering on what the British people
voted for okay uh are you looking at
staying in the European Economic Area
and a customs union as a potential
alternative if your deal is defeated is
there any internal planning going on in
number ten as I have made clear my focus
is on the vote that will take place in
the December here in this house I think
we understand yes I'm sorry but is
really a planning I'm sorry is going on
for that what what I am focused on and
what the government is focused on is the
vote that will take place on December
the 11th you want to look at all sorts
of options and ideas and so on as over I
think it's important that members of
parliament focus on the nature of this
vote this is an important point in our
history it is a vote on which we will be
deciding whether to deliver on the will
of the British people and the good deal
that I put forward does that in a way
that I understand any sensible
government will be planning in case the
deal doesn't go through and the question
I'm asking you is is there planning
going on for a different approach if the
deal is defeated because it'd be very
strange if you said to us there's no
planning going on the what's to be made
clear from the European Union and was
made clear at the weekend is that this
is the deal that has been negotiated and
this is the deal that people need to
focus on when they're looking at the at
the vote okay the Chancellor also said
yesterday that there will be a cost to
leaving the European Union because there
will be impediments to trade he's right
isn't he well there will be the the
question when this is often put in a
variety of ways this issue about what
will happen when we leave the European
Union obviously this analysis that's
been provided by the Bank of England
short term analysis short term forecast
of what would happen in a no deal
scenario the government's analysis that
was provided to Parliament sets out a
number of potential it looks at
different comparisons No Deal the
government's might pay for EI and the
and earth sort of average free-trade
agreement what that looks at is the
impact of trade we've all we've all read
that one thing surely that is clear from
that that No Deal is no longer better
than a bad deal because that would be
the worst outcome of all wouldn't it
well that depends on what a bad deal
looks like I suggest but the obviously
the impact of No Deal has been forecast
at the request of the Treasury select
committee by the by the Bank of England
if you look at the issues that have been
raised by this analysis what they show
is that the deal that we have negotiated
is the best deal for jobs in the economy
which honors the referendum and enables
us to take is there a worse deal than no
deal
well this deal the deal we've negotiated
is certainly not that it's a good deal
but you just said that no deal might not
be the worst outcome because there could
be an even worse one what could that be
well there isn't on the table that is in
that category okay thank you very much
thank you coming out of Richards
Thank You terminan thank you very much
Prime Minister for coming to give
evidence to us this morning following on
from what Hilary Benn said and given the
analysis both by the bank and by the
government yesterday on how catastrophic
and no deer would be I know that the
Prime Minister takes her
responsibilities to our country very
seriously will therefore the Prime
Minister rule out that whatever happens
in the vote on the 11th of December that
her government would consider leaving
the European Union without a deal we
will be leaving the European Union on
the 29th of March 2019 and when we come
to the vote on the 11th of December it
will be
members of parliament to determine
whether they want to deliver on the vote
that the British people took and whether
they want to do that with a good deal
which actually does protect people's
jobs into the future that is we we are
promoting a good deal but that's respect
promise and that wasn't my question I'm
asking whether you will rule out the
possibility that on the 29th of March we
could leave the European Union without a
deal given what we know now from the
Bank of England from your government's
own analysis will you rule that out as a
possibility it would be so catastrophic
the the decision that the House of
Commons will take on the 11th of
December it will be whether to support
whether to ratify the deal that the
United Kingdom government has negotiated
with the Europeans if the House votes
down that deal at that point then there
will be some steps that will be
necessary because obviously we've been
doing No Deal planning as a government
we've made certain information available
to businesses but at a point at which
the if the house were to vote down the
deal that has been agreed given that the
European Union has been clear that this
is the deal that has been agreed and
this is the deal that is on the table
then obviously decisions would have to
be taken subordination to the action
that would need to focus on the deal on
the 11th of December would you really
prime minister given what we now know
from the analysis contemplate taking
Britain out of the European Union the
29th of March without a deal without
your deal without any if Parliament
votes down the deal on the 11th of
December there will there is then a
process as you know that is in the
legislation for the length of time for
given for government to come back and
make a statement about the next steps
but the timetable is such that actually
some people would need to take some
practical steps in relation to No Deal
if the government were to vote if the
Parliament were to vote down the deal on
the 11th of December okay let's turn now
to your deal it's disappointing Prime
Minister that your deal the withdrawal
agreement and the political declaration
were not modeled in the government's own
and instead the analysis is on the July
white paper rather than your deal why
was that Prime Minister is it because
frankly there is insufficient detail in
the political declaration to model it at
all the as you know the political
declaration sets a spectrum in relation
to the balance of rights and obligations
of access to the market versus
acceptance of of rules which has
obviously an impact on checks at the
border what we have done that is and the
detail of that is being negotiated it is
still open for frictionless trade what I
have said in the House of Commons is
this might be an honest with people we
haven't persuaded everybody in Europe
yet about absolutely frictionless trade
the ambition is there to be as near
fiction lists in political declaration
to be as near frictionless as possible
what we did do I thought it was right to
do was to set out the sensitivity
analysis of that spectrum and we took a
midpoint on that spectrum which is the
50% sensitivity analysis which has been
identified and I think if you look at
some of the comments that have been
given about the analysis that the
government has put forward for example
the chief economist of the IFG has been
clear that they set tests that we needed
to address to ensure MPs and others were
able to scrutinize the modelling and
interpret appropriately and those tests
the published report passes those tests
and is something that should be taken
seriously given that in July the white
paper had in it frictionless trade and
as you just said Prime Minister the
political declaration wasn't able to
achieve that objective can we assume
that the the outcome of the the
political declaration without
frictionless trade will be a worse
economic outcome than what was in the
July white paper the what the analysis
has shown is a 50 percent sensitivity
point there's a spectrum in relation to
that that analysis which as course goes
alongside the spectrum of checks versus
access to the markets but it is not the
case it is still the government's
position that we will be negotiating to
achieve frictionless trade what you see
in the political declaration and you'll
see it in the language around the
ambition for us
customs arrangements in the future is a
clear recognition of the need to reduce
that friction as much as possible I
think it's still better to reduce it to
to have frictionless trade but as I say
there are those in the European Union
who have yet to be persuaded of that
argument the European you know very much
in favor of frictionless trade that's
why they're in the single market in the
customs union Prime Minister and you
said yesterday in Prime Minister's
Questions that the the the analysis does
not show that will be poorer in the
future but the government analysis
published yesterday shows that will be a
hundred billion pounds a year as a
country worse off at 1,100 pounds per
person per year so can you confirm that
under all scenarios analysed by the
government analysis we will be poor in
the future compared with our current
position in the European Union that's
what the government analysis shows isn't
it Prime Minister I explained what I
said in the Prime Minister's Questions
and I made that point I think if you
went out to remember the public and said
we're going to be poorer outside the
European Union than inside the European
than we are today they poor outside the
EU they assume you mean poorer than
today actually that's not what we're
saying what we're saying is the economy
will continue to grow we will be better
off in the future the question is about
the relative rates of growth on in the
in the different models that are
identified the point is that being
inside the European Union is not an
option but now secures hands well we
know that we have to look at is what is
the best option outside the European
Union because people have voted to leave
the EU and the best what the analysis
shows is that the best option outside
the European Union which obviously
delivers on the vote by being outside
the EU but it's also the best for jobs
in the entire
compared with our current
with the European Union yes or no what
what the analysis shows is that there
will be an impact on the growth on the
rate of growth in the United Kingdom
looking ahead other things being equal
but of collapse and other things in
negative but no other thoughts
other things will not necessarily be
equal this is why I made a slightly what
some might require record a slightly
flipped comment about forecasts and
economic forecasts in response to a
question in the statement I think on
Monday or last week but the point is
that there are many variables that can
change that will impact in relation to
what happens to our economy outside the
outside the European Union some of those
are in our hands and decisions that we
will be taking as a government obviously
there are other other aspects in terms
of the internet international trade in
2020 ninety percent of the growth in
growth is due to be outside models with
respect prime minister in the governor
it's not all no no it's not all model
trade assumptions about the growth in
the rest of the world is is modelled and
the trade assumptions are in the
government's analysis the government's
analysis show onto all scenarios we will
be poorer compared with our current
relationship that is what the government
analysis shows can I just be clear the
government analysis does not identify
does not deal with all the issues that
I've spoken about it because it doesn't
deal with decisions that government
might take in clarifies primary account
it assumes that we've come to trade
deals through the United States
Australia New Zealand and other
countries so that trade assumptions are
in the analysis Prime Minister honestly
you have said that austerity is coming
to an end but all the economic analysis
shows they'll be less government income
when we leave so how are you going to
end austerity well we're already showing
how we end austerity we're showing how
we end austerity in the in the budget
we're showing how we end all story but
nobody plan is so putting in the
national so that's now but I'm saying
when we leave they're gonna be less
money and yet as you've said austerity
is coming to an end
and there's a 20 billion going into NHS
for example but there's a lot of other
demands as my committee of highlights
routinely how are we going to end
austerity with the financial challenges
we'll have
well the what we are going to do in
terms of ending austerity is ensure that
we are able to continue to deal with our
debt and see our debt falling but and
put more money into public services we
will be doing that as our economy grows
into the future as the economy will
continue to grow into into the prime
minister said you've just lost a
minister but you've said too and
responds to Rachel Reeves the economy
will grow at a lower rate in your view
on the basis of this economic analysis
so there's less money coming in so will
you be raising taxes or increasing debt
the economic analysis shows the trade
impact and that trade impact shows the
impact on the rate of growth in the
future other things being equal other
things of course will not necessarily be
equal in terms of government decisions
and and so forth so that's why I say
that you have to be very careful when
you quote the analysis in looking at
exactly what what it is but if you look
at the but in the spending review next
year we will be setting out the spending
path and plans for the government over
the next few three years when we're
outside the European Union now there are
many there are many aspects that will go
into that there are also many issues I
mean I could point out to you not in
answer to your question but I would
point out as a separate point perhaps
we're the Bank of England analysis
actually shows that our deal does have
that sort of deal dividend for the bank
but the Bank of England analysis your
mock corn he has said always we see the
worst recession since the 30s so there
will be less money coming in the
spending review the most benefit
analysis is in No Deal situation yes
well that's one of the options that sat
out there as the chair and highlighted
we have a very rocky vote coming up in
the next 13 days so given where we are
at now given that the spending review
could be a will be the first post brexit
spending set up for the government that
will be less money available not under
any analysis especially if we crash out
how are you going to end austerity it
was that spending review going to be a
cuts round you will I'm not going to sit
here and tell you what the spending
review is going to have in it before we
before the spending review is you have
simply have to I could raise tax
or you could increase their the simple
options I mean obviously there's a lot
more to it but well there is a lot more
to it with due respect I think you
understand that there's a lot more to it
and those are not and there's just look
look at some of the circumstances back
in the summer when we announced the
money into the National Health Service
we spoke I mean there is the money that
we will no longer be paying into the
European Union but we also spoke about
we also spoke about the fact that at
that stage we thought we might need to
ask people to contribute more through
taxes in new money that we're putting in
the National Health Service what we then
saw in the budget is that we have been
able to show how we fund that fund that
National Health Service increase in
without actually asking people to raise
taxes so this is why I'm saying you
don't
there is aren't absolute I think one is
how you do why all you do that so we can
there are many variables in things we
get a lot of mirrors from ministers
about how finance or no government
finances is going but today we hear that
the Met Police and certainly experience
of mine in my constituency and not
investigating a third of all crimes
we've heard through my committee we see
routinely real challenges in the public
services so if you're starett is over
you're going to have to fund that
somehow we're going to have a less money
coming in after bricks it so what's the
plan and you will see how we will be
funding our public services over the
next three years when we announce our
spending review right well and all the
withdrawal agreements as my colleague
has highlighted that hasn't been
properly modeled yet is that other plans
to have some modeling of that before
Parliament before the vote the
withdrawal agreement if they plan
Thermidor agreement and the political
agreement is political declaration is
the is the sets out I've been clear
about what the government will be aiming
to achieve but the analogy of government
across an analysis looked at this
different options but not the option
that's before us that's the point
well there is aspects and will it's not
doing will you be doing that there is a
spectrum that is identified in the
political declaration we will be
negotiating in relation to the rights
and obligations and access to market
versus checks that will be necessary
what we have done in the analysis and it
is in I think it's entirely Russian
proper and that is accepted
but external bodies we have put the
sensitivity analysis so that people can
see have some idea of the impact of the
variation of where we appear on that
spectrum the aim of the political
declaration the clear intent of the
political declaration is to be as low
down that spectrum as possible I I will
continue to argue for it to be
frictionless okay is there any more
information going to be coming to
Parliament before the vote about the
economic impacts of BRICS it on the
basis of the deal that you strong we
would provided the analysis okay would
say so just move on to the preparedness
agreement we've my committee has
produced knowing unanimous reports in
the last year looking at government
preparedness and there's a real concern
that the very best outcome is a
suboptimal especially if we crash out
without a deal so what what are you
going to be doing to make sure that
there is proper support for business and
tax payers generally to deal with the
out for a brexit given that the we and
we have shown demonstrably showing the
government departments are can be ready
in time well government departments are
as you know the Treasury has put money
made money available to government
departments to deal with both preparing
for a deal and preparing for no deal
that's entirely right and proper all
those arrangement we know the money's
there happening but but there haven't
they haven't they acknowledge many of
your civil sense of knowledge that it's
suboptimal that they're not going to go
to deliver everything perfectly on 29th
of March do you agree with them they
well on the 29th March if we agree the
withdrawal agreement of course what we
will be doing is seeing will be leaving
the European Union but the
implementation period will give us that
period of time when we continue to
operate be operating much as today and
therefore the that the issue I think
your questioning is no deal preparations
if we come out on the 29th of March
without a deal what would the
preparations because I've just made
clear of course there will be some key
decisions to be taken depending on the
outcome of the vote on the 11th of
December Thank You Prime Minister
certainly were in Scotland yesterday for
a flying visit and what seemed almost
like a valiant attempt to drum up
opposition to your deal
Scotland will be worse off because of
what you proposed the Scottish
Government Rep
that could be up to 1600 pounds per
person for every Scot we didn't vote to
leave the European Union apparently no
70% of people want to steam
why should Scots even start to think of
it again behind you do this is a good
deal for the whole of the United Kingdom
if you look at what is what we've seen
in Scotland we've seen this being
supported by the Scottish fisherman's
Federation by the National Farmers Union
of Scotland by employers like Diageo
where I was yesterday at Brigid we're
and we were discussing their supply
chains across Europe the importance of
no tariffs the political declaration is
clear no tariffs no quantitative
restrictions no rules of origin
requirements these are good for
employers across Scotland we and we went
into the ICI is the whole United Kingdom
movie we live it leaving supported by
more Scots 70% according to this opinion
poll opposed to us every single local
authority area voted to remain in the UK
remain in the EU it's a message from
Scotland to you now is not the time to
be leaving the EU to make us pooter we
have negotiated a deal that would be
good for jobs and good for the Scottish
economy and that is that is reflected in
the remarks that have been made by as I
say employers and other oil and
organisations in in Scotland Scotland is
part of the United Kingdom and what is
of course most important for the
Scottish economy is its continuation
inside the internal market of the United
Kingdom apology rejects so utterly every
representation that was made to you by
the Democratic way to Scottish
government to try and soften the impact
to Scotland you you look to issues
across what you call the family of
nations of the United Kingdom and all of
them are managed to secure some sort of
differential dealing agreement which
sort of matches their own specific
population economic profile I was all
right for every other part of the UK
family but it wasn't alright for
Scotland No well first of all I'm afraid
I don't accept the premise of the
question that you've given to me what we
do have
particular arrangements for Northern
Ireland because Northern Ireland is in a
different situation from any other part
of the United Kingdom because it will
have a land border with the country that
is a member of the European Union we
have also the other two protocols which
are specific to the wider United Kingdom
family of the protocol in relation to
Gibraltar and in relation to the
sovereign base areas on Cyprus it is not
the case that every single part of the
United Kingdom or the United Kingdom
family has a specific arrangement made
it almost seems like it to us a correct
answer emigration and I think one of you
was one of them achieve never consume
your most crude about I think is the
ending of freedom of movement no
Scotland's Scotland's population growth
is almost totally predicated on any word
immigration is absolutely vital to our
population demography and to our economy
and can I just get this absolutely
abundantly clear that what you will be
doing is stopping people below a
threshold of 30,000 pounds from coming
to the United Kingdom and that will
mainly be what we call people with more
skills and young people at the beginning
of the kicker's is that roughly the
understanding what you're trying to
achieve by ending freedom and movement
yeah what I'm what I'm what we're doing
is delivering on the vote that replace
ending free movement I believe was a key
issue for many people here in the United
Kingdom and we will be ending free
movement will bring an end to free
movement what this will enable us to do
is to put into place an immigration
system which applies to the whole of the
world outside the United Kingdom up
until now we've been able to have
immigration rules for countries outside
the EU but not for countries inside the
EU we will be able to have a single
immigration system that covers all of
those we ask the independent migration
advisory committee to look into this
issue to consider the shape and form
that such an immigration system could
sure to take taking into account the
requirements of the UK economy they did
that and their proposal was that rather
than having a tear to cap a number set
which we've had up till now for
beside the European Union we should move
to a skills-based system and the propose
with the proposed salary threshold which
would determine really really helpful
but it's a reciprocal agreement so what
we do to European Union Nationals they
will do to us
so that means that people with more
skills from the United Kingdom
young people at the beginning of the
careers will equally not be allowed the
same rates of access to the European
Union no well first of all you've jumped
to an assumption there what I was
talking about was the immigration system
that will be independently put into
place by Europe you have it was what we
do - you're making an assumption you I
have to say I don't think so yes
young Brits to go abroad as they have
just know before we've we've been
looking at a variety of a variety of
issues in relation to young people
particularly one of the areas that we've
looked at is the sort of programs such
as Erasmus which have enabled that the
you know students to take advantage of
membership of the European Union but if
you look at the the section within the
political declaration you will see that
of course we will be looking at the
mobility arrangements that are Italy's
Prime Minister that the rates at you and
I had to live work and love across a
continent the 28 nations is going to be
deprived to early young people because
of your obsession with immigration no
and I refer you to article 53 the
parties agreed to consider conditions
for entry and stay for purposes such as
research study training and youth
exchanges so you're not indicative in
the movement name yes we are ending
freedom of movement we are ending
freedom what freedom and freedom of
movement gives them gives automatic
rights to people living in the European
Union that are not available to people
outside the European Union in future we
will end that automatic right that comes
with free movement what we will put in
place is our system of immigration rules
which will apply across
all countries and it will be
skills-based rather than based on the
country that somebody is right from the
European Union to Prime Minister we're
not going to move on to security defense
and borders starting with Dr Ng Primus -
good morning good morning
can I start by just saying huge respect
for the energy that you've applied to
this in trying to get the best deal
possible for our country nobody could
have worked harder than you can I ask
you firstly what plans you have to
govern in the event that you win the
vote on the 21st of December given that
you will be doing so without the DUP
that is a game there are a lot of
questions which are based on assumptions
the we obviously are talking to the DUP
as we are talking to other members of
parliament about the vote that will take
place on the on the 11th of December but
nevertheless you have to plan for the
worst case scenario and it's highly
likely given the remarks made by Arlene
Foster that you will be facing the
future without your confidence and
supply partner the actually the DUP have
themselves said that the confidence in
supply agreement remains in place the I
saw Arlene Foster and other
representatives in the DUP as I did Shin
feign Alliance SDLP and the UUP when I
was in Northern Ireland on Tuesday and
we discussed yes the concerns that the
DUP have raised with the some of the
arrangements that are in the withdrawal
agreement and obviously there are some
issues which with which they're
concerned which fall to the UK
government is a sovereign decision to
consider our response to it so if you
win on the - on the 11th of December you
expect the DEP to continue much as they
are at the moment they support as I say
they have said themselves that the
competence in supply agreement remains
in place can you name a single trade
agreement outside the Eurasian customs
union that does not allow a party to the
agreement to withdraw on notice of than
the one proposed in the withdrawal
agreement so I can I name a single trade
do you say - a trade arrangement a trade
arrangement anywhere in the world which
doesn't allow one part
part of party to withdraw on giving
sufficient notice there is that
obviously what we have here in the
withdrawal agreement is an agreement
which sets out the arrangements for us
leaving the European Union and within
that the backstop the protocol for
Northern Ireland which ensures that at
all stages if it is the case that the
future relationship is not in place we
are able to continue to meet our
guarantee to the people of Northern
Ireland that there'll be no hard border
between North Ireland and Ireland
within the withdrawal agreement it is
set out there are ways in which it is
possible to end that backstop obviously
the best way is not to use it in the
first place the second is to get into
the future relationship there are
alternative it doesn't have to be used
even when we haven't got the future
relationship in place in time but there
are we can ensure that there are
arrangements in place the key here is
always ensuring through the arrangements
that we see in that withdrawal agreement
prior to the future relationship coming
into place which deals with this that we
deal with the commitment cannot we
cannot unilaterally withdraw from this
arrangement there is there isn't a
unilateral withdrawal dolls but if you
think about the nature of the insurance
policy that the backstop is this is
about ensuring and committing to the
people of Northern Ireland that there
will be no hard border between north and
Ireland and Ireland and that means that
in the circumstances where the future
relationship which would deal with that
the future relationship is not in place
the question is what then comes in as
you know this is what's come to be known
as backstop the C extension of the IP as
possibility of alternative arrangements
all of those clearly from the withdrawal
agreement would only be temporary that's
all that's all understood Prime Minister
and is well laid out juche am i worried
that the backstop protocol is a bit like
a post-war prefab it sold as temporary
it's built to last and it's likely to
outlive us all no I don't
and and there are a number of reasons
why I don't first of all there there are
many as you will see there were a number
of references throughout the withdrawal
agreement that indicate that this is
only temporary
one of those of course is the issue
about article 50 which cannot in itself
as a legal base lead to a permanent
relationship but the it is also it's not
just the what's in the withdrawal
agreement but actually the if you look
at the backstop
neither side thinks at the backstop is a
good place to be in the United Kingdom
is worried about the implications in the
backstop but the European Union is
worried about the implications to the
backstop as well do you think its
president for example in the backstop if
we don't if we haven't agreed an
agreement for access to fishing waters
which by definition almost certainly
wouldn't be because of the future
relation if you're in the backstop you
haven't got the future relationship and
that agreement will be in the future
relationship then the European Union
would have no access you've anticipated
my question because I was going to ask
you what you felt about president
macrons comments because he clearly
doesn't agree about the temporary nature
of the backstop or indeed his ability to
secure more advantages from the United
Kingdom if we came to the point at which
we wished to remove ourselves from the
arrangement well as I as I think I said
the other day I think it'll be good for
peasant mackerel and others to perhaps
recall the position that will apply in
the backstop which I is the one that
I've just set out which if there is no
agreement on access to two waters and
that agreement of course is part of the
future relationship the the agreement of
how we negotiate those access to waters
if that is not in place which by
definition if you're in the backstop it
wouldn't be because if it's in the
future relationship he wouldn't be in
the backstop if the future relationship
was it was in place then there would be
no access to UK waters yeah okay thank
you if we if you lose on the 11th of
December would you consider going back
to the European Union and suggesting
that the time limit to the backstop that
was being negotiated in the summer is
still being talked about in Dublin
through
example might be inserted which is
likely to get it over the line for a
number of colleagues and might just
about get this through the House of
Commons do you think that's a
possibility if you lose on the 11th of
December well there's the temporary
nature the backstop is is within the
withdrawal agreement at no stage was
there any indication that a set time
limit for the backstop could be in the
withdrawal agreement what stops the
backstop is the future relationship or
alternative arrangements being put in
place that enable us to continue to
guarantee give our guarantee to the
people of earth Northern Ireland for the
for the future for the no heart border
and indeed the European Union's made
clear that there's no deal without a
backstop and I mean the the tea shop
just a couple of days ago made the point
that you you can't I mean he wasn't
talking about he wouldn't speculate on
No Deal you can't you can't avoid a hard
border just through goodwill political
statements and wishful thinking actually
you need to have the agreements in place
that enable that to take place
thank you my minister everybody knows
that the prospect of a so-called hard
border between Northern Ireland and the
Irish Republic has been a crucial factor
in forcing us to stay in a customs union
so please tell us under what
circumstances could a hard or to be
erected between Northern Ireland and the
Irish Republic
well first of all if I may dr. Lewis the
we are not being fought but that the the
statement being forced to stay in a
customs union might imply to some who
are listening that that is going to be
the long-term permanent relationship at
the United Kingdom of the European Union
it is not this is a temporary
arrangement for until the future
relationship is in place it need never
happen can we come back to my question
though under what circumstances could a
hard border be erected between Northern
Ireland and the Irish Republic the
circumstances in which
you have said that we would do
everything in our power to avoid not to
exercise but we are not the only party
to this to this arrangement the
obviously there is the Irish government
in fact competence in this is a matter
for the European Union as I've just said
as the tea shock has made clear well
sometimes it's said to me well everybody
says they won't have a hard border
receive the point is made is its you
can't rely you say mister don't you
can't just rely on political statements
for heart no harm a border you have to
actually have the arrangements in place
that enable no heart borders to be
erected mister you still haven't
answered the question
under what circumstances could a
hardcore to be erected or are there no
circumstances under which a hard border
would be erected for example if we leave
on 29th of March without a deal and I
know you don't want us to do doing
everything to avoid our leaving without
a deal but if we do would there have to
be a part
it is that there will be that the
potentially in the No Deal scenario we
would do everything we could not to
erect a hot water all right it would be
a decision from the European Union and
the Irish government and the concern
that that they would have would be about
the fact that we would then be in a
different certain set of circumstances
on customs yes I'm not gonna and how do
you check those you're not gonna tell me
any specific circumcised beer do you
accept that there are some circumstances
under which a hard border might have to
be erected
well that's theirs otherwise what are we
worried well that's that
that's the point the point is that
because you cannot guarantee that there
would be no hard border there all
circumstances unless we have put in the
arrangements to ensure there is no hard
border right but let's let's assume
because things don't always work out the
way we want me to work out let's assume
that we're in some scenario whereby a
hard border needed to be erected
now who would under those circumstances
whatever they may be
who would insist on a hard border
actually being built if for example we
leave with no deal in place who would
insist on a hard border being built if
people fell too hard no there has to be
built with the UK under any
circumstances insist on putting in a
hard order with the Irish Republic on
any under any circumstances insist on
putting in a hard border or would the EU
itself in any circumstances insist on
putting in a hard border well I can only
speak for the UK government you know I
have made clear that if there is we
leave the European Union
No Deal scenario we will do everything
in our power to avoid the being a hard
border right so let's assume then that
in circumstances unspecified somebody is
insisting that there must be a hard
border who would actually build it would
the UK build it with the Irish Republic
build it or with the EU builder now I
asked you this question on the 17th of
October but you didn't answer it you
merely stated we are all working to
ensure there will be no hard border
between those and Ireland in Ireland so
please answer it now who would
physically put this hard border in place
we certainly wouldn't the Irish
certainly wouldn't and how could the EU
possibly do it if neither of us were
going to do so the first again you have
as I can only speak for the United
Kingdom government in these in these
matters and we have said that we would
do everything to avoid the being a hard
border on the between Northern Ireland
and Ireland other's decisions for the
other parties in this our decisions for
them yes for me but if they took those
decisions Prime Minister they would find
it impossible to implement because we
would not build it for them and the
Irish wouldn't build it for them so
unless they're anticipating sending in
the EU army to build it forward it would
never be built so the whole thing
amounts does it not to an excuse to keep
us entangled with the European Union for
fear of building a border that is never
gonna happen under any scenario
whatsoever that's the truth no it is not
and I just I do disagree with what are
the sign disagree with that and I think
it is important and if I may just
address this point there's this
assumption or this this sort of point
that is made that somehow this question
of the heart border in Northern Ireland
is a matter that has been pushed on the
United Kingdom government by the
European Union and all the government of
Republic
it is not we have a commitment to the
people of Northern Ireland they are part
of the United Kingdom I want them to be
able to continue to lead their lives
very much as they do today when we leave
the European Union not having a hard
border and enabling businesses to
operate as they do today is an important
part of that commitment that we have
made and if I may refer again to the
remarks that the tea shop made what I
will say is that you can't avoid a hard
border just through goodwill political
statements and wishful thinking it is
important it is important for us to
recognize that we have a commitment to
the people of Northern Ireland now I
believe that commitment is best met as
does the tea shock as does the European
Union through the future relationship we
are going to have with the with the
European Union that is why it's
important that we that we have within
the withdrawal agreement the commitments
for both sides using their best
endeavours to ensure that relationship
is in place by the end of December 2020
so there is no question of a backstop no
question of an extension to an
implementation period no question of
alternative arrangements because they
are in it is dealt with in the future
just to stop now but I can only Justin
don't you have not shown who would
physically erected and the answer is no
we're going to event
Prime Minister I know that you do
rightly care about the North risks to
Moorman security you also care immensely
about and know about the security risks
to the country and the economic risk to
the country if there is no deal so
knowing you for 20 years
I just don't believe that if your deal
goes down you are the kind of person who
would contemplate taking this country
into a no deal situation am I wrong
the decision decision for Parliament as
to whether they accept the deal that I
am the government of negotiated on
behalf of the United Kingdom with the
European
I believe that's a good deal sound
sounding I don't want to go over the
three-year sense it's my issue is I
don't believe you are the kind of person
who could contemplate No Deal even if
you don't get this steel I don't think
you'll do it I think you'll take action
to avert it I know Ron in my judgment
about you um well I've had a number of
questions now about what happens if what
I'm saying is very simple my focus is on
December that's fine I was asking
actually goes because I've negotiated
what I believe truly to be a good deal
for the you okay and all I was asking
about the kind of person that I think
you are but let me ask then go into the
specifics of the deal
can you confirm we don't have access
agreed to the sis to database or the
equus database in the political
declaration we don't have the sister
database and the equus database
specifically identified in the in the
political deck usually pushed for those
leads what we what we do have is
reference to exchange of information on
in wanted or missing persons objects and
but it no records well of course are
what sis to and Equus covers but you've
tried to get a specific reference you
have got reference to prom you have got
reference to pay or not so you've
achieved some access to specific things
but you haven't got access to those but
your security assessment assumes that
you have I mean that is not being
straight with people about the risks to
security of what you've currently got in
your political declaration and in your
agreement well the but what the
political declaration makes clear is
that as part of the future negotiations
the nature of the access to those on
that data exchange will be part of the
future negotiations but it is with a
view to delivering any per bilities but
insofar as is technically and legally
possible and considered necessary okay
consider it necessary and in both
parties intra but it but it doesn't they
say
spy but this is this is about whether or
not we have the capability or whether or
not we're in a specific but you're still
traveling around this you haven't got
agreement to it and it is a risk you
know how important it is let me ask you
specifically about borders and customs
when you says in paragraph 23 we're
going to build and improve on the single
customs territory does that mean
alignment to the common external tariff
no because it goes on as what it makes
absolutely clear that it's in line with
the part of objectives and principles
above which includes us being an
independent able to have an independent
trade okay so if we don't have alignment
to the common external tariff why did
you tell Parliament on Monday that we've
got an agreement to no rules of origins
checks that is within the if you look
within the text of the political
declaration you will see the it's
paragraph 23 what it says is build and
improve on the single customs territory
provided for in the withdrawal agreement
which includes alignment to the common
external tariff which obviates the need
for checks on rules of origin so your
current to the checks for rules of
origins is only in the context of the
single customs territory which includes
our core alignment to the common
external tariff no the the if you think
back to that it is wrong to assume that
the only way to obviate the needs for
rules of origin checks is for the United
Kingdom to be only able to expert to
apply the common external tariff that is
not the case what's the other way the
government publishes of white paper in
July that showed the showed another way
of doing I see come back to check is the
government's our disagreement so this is
the the max facts or the customs
partnership and stuff that we know the
EU has rejected know the you know the
you know one of the key elements of the
political declaration is that the
European Union did start off from the
position of saying that there were no
Americans that would be available to the
United Kingdom other than that what come
to be in shorthand the Norway
or the Canada model a counter only 4gb
in fact what they have now accepted is
that there is you know that yeah Takeda
will have a different relationship with
the European Union an unprecedented
relationship with the European Union
because we will not just be any third
country and that means that we're
looking for an ambition in our customs
arrangement which is set out within the
political declaration is made yo you
still only on ambition I mean here's
your problem is you're trying to say to
some people that you're gonna get a
frictionless trade you're gonna be
pretty close to normal you're trying to
say to other people you're going to be
pretty close to Canada and you're gonna
have a free and independent trade policy
actually you haven't got agreement to
any of those and in your head you're
just resting on checkers and your max
facts things that's already being
rejected so once again you're just not
being straight with people and isn't
your real problem here that because you
haven't got agreement to any of this
because it is still a spectrum as your
own documents say actually you're really
saying to people trust me I'll sort it
out in the second phase but because
you're not being straight with people on
any of these things insist to on whether
or not we're going to be poorer on
whether or not we're gonna have rules of
arrogance checks not able to build up
that trust well first of all you said
that none of the what I heard said was
had been agreed with in the political
declaration including the fact that we
would have an independent trade policy
it is specifically referenced in the
political declaration it was important
for the United Kingdom that we've got
that reference into the political
declaration that the European Union
accents that we will have an independent
trade policy outside of the European
Union that is a major the the
assumptions around obviously it's been a
lot of talk about whether it would be
better to stay in the customs union
which of course would not enable us to
have that in
abandoned trade policy and the the the
model as you say one end of the the to
one of the two models that the European
Union originally started off thinking
that we would need to have would have
require that it would also not have
ended free movement but what we have is
you haven't got a spin down yes what we
have in this political declaration is
agreements on the yes I think I was
clear about the fact in relation to
frictionless absolutely frictionless as
opposed to as near frictionless as
possible but we've got agreement in
relation to no terrace fees charges or
quantitative restrictions across all
sectors and this is only what is also
clear in this is that the next stage
gives effect to this relationship
promise identity writing anything I
don't get stomped you can hats turn
thank you very much for your points so
far and I recognize your unwillingness
to protect and on a questionable future
could we at least look at a certain past
and ask what have you learned from these
negotiations given that we're now only
about halfway through anyway I'm not
sure it's something that I've learnt
specifically from these negotiations
because obviously I was involved in
certain negotiations of the UN I was
Home Secretary I think what there's been
reinforced by these negotiations is that
actually if we are rigorous and robust
in our defence of our position then we
can change the view in the European
Union I think one of the best examples
of that is what I've just been talking
about they started off saying you can
only be Norway or Canada for GB but
actually now they've accepted an
ambitious customs relationship a trade
relationship that is beyond anything
that any other advanced economy has with
them you've made that point before and I
it's noticeable that they have moved on
some areas surely there are some things
that you would now having conducted some
of the most complex negotiations this
country is conducted in peacetime there
are some things that you would do
differently where you to be in 2016
today well the as I say I think the if
you look at the no see
the lesson that can be taken from it is
that it's and it's it's not just I think
sometimes people look at negotiations as
sort of great theater pieces I think
what we've seen from the work that has
been done that actually the way that you
get through and the way that you get
change is through patient and
painstaking argument on the issues and
on the detail of the issues I would
certainly agree with you that the detail
is the fundament of what you're arguing
hence the 585 pages we've all had the
privilege to read it for the last few
weeks but surely some of this is to do
with the structure as well and there
must be some elements of the structure
that you may feel that you wish to do
differently for example the fact that
David Davis appears to have only been in
Brussels for a few days to negotiate
with Barney does rather question whether
or not a brexit Department was the right
way to go or whether it would be better
to bring the levers of foreign influence
under the Foreign Office or indeed under
you and through the Cabinet Office well
of course there has been I mean this I
think it was absolutely right to set up
the department for exiting the European
Union because there are different there
are a number of functions of that
department is undertaking and crucially
of course one of the things that the
department has been doing is looking at
the preparedness for all scenarios
preparedness for dealing preparedness
for no deal and that is something that's
been led by that department of course
negotiations were always going to be
across government they've been other
departments involved in negotiations
where the it has been a specific and
issue specific to those departments
so it was meted the case in these [ __ ]
Asians and it won't be in the future
negotiations that it's just that person
against one person actually it takes a
lot of work streams and a lot of people
across departments being involved in in
it
the reason I ask is because there are a
few moments that frankly have left me
somewhat surprised certainly seeing you
walking out of the meeting in Salzburg
where to see the Prime Minister of the
United Kingdom surprised at the outcome
of one of the most important talks that
has been conducted on behalf of this
nation did raise certain questions as to
whether or not the Foreign Office had
prepared its advice properly whether the
advice had been fed through properly or
whether it had been fully taken on board
and what the power on the Secretary of
State Hasan and McDonnell said the other
day to our committee was that the advice
had been prepared properly so why were
you apparently surprised by the reaction
of the European leaders and does this
suggest that there is a better way of
coordinating for the next stage of talks
well I think the it is certainly I have
no complaint with the advice that was
that was given by the Foreign Office or
indeed by that all the others that were
involved in this I think all I would say
is that there are sometimes moments in
these negotiations where particular a
particular position is taken and we in
any negotiation either side when the
other side takes a position has a
decision to take as to how to react to
that and I felt it was right to react in
the way that I did and in a last point
if I may
the brexit Department has clearly got a
very different role today to the one
envisaged when it was set up as it's now
in reality that the Department for No
Deal does this mean that you'll be
looking to change some of the servants
from diplomats involved in trade
negotiations to Home Affairs health
transport and others more involved in
domestic policy to focus on preparing
the United Kingdom for a No Deal rather
than preparing us for the negotiations
well the the the job that Dec Zoo is
doing is preparing for yes it has a role
in Iran does have a role in preparing
for No Deal it also has a role in
preparing for a deal but it's not that
you need all the expertise index it
actually they do work and they have been
bringing civil servants from across
departments with particular
areas of expertise index you to look to
be dealing with these issues but the
obviously it works with other
departments as well so if you look at a
department like d'etre they have had
because there's a department probably
most affected in legislative terms in
terms of numbers of piece of legislation
for the veu they have themselves
obviously been doing a lot of the work
involved in preparedness Dec sue has an
overall responsibility for that and
ensuring that the cross governmental
activity is undertaken in a way that
works and also that the Department of
work with one department isn't
inadvertently you know affecting the
work of another department cuz I just
finally clarifies it despite the fact
that we've gone through the most complex
divorce talks that any country has been
through and despite the fact we're about
to enter the most complex marriage
negotiations through this free trade
agreement that we're hoping to negotiate
with you with the European Union
there is no stage of wish you'd wish to
change either the Yenter or the
structure in which the marriage broker
organizes herself well I think I'm not
sure that a remarriage is perhaps the
correct analogy for the relationship
that is going to be in the future we're
going to be very good friends and
working closely working it did I miss
your quick I'm sorry friends with
benefits prime minister but obviously we
look as we go through this process we
will continue to look as we have been
because as you probably know we've made
some changes over the summer to Dec sue
to the relative roles of deck sue in the
Cabinet Office so we have throughout
this process we look to make sure that
we have the right people in the right
place thank you can you just confirm
that we will definitely have the
immigration white paper published before
the meaningful vote on the 11th of
December the there is still discussion
ongoing as to the timing of the did you
see that it's really important that it's
published before the meaningful vote and
can you guarantee that that will happen
well the the what the you're expecting
people to vote for your deal but and and
bearing in mind the political
declaration surely we need to know what
you have in mind for the immigration
rules this country before we vote on the
11th of December
well we've set out in obviously set out
the outline of the immigration rules
that we're going to have in the future
but our immigration policy is a separate
policy decision but will we have the
deal but we may have with the tail vote
I
as I say we are still in discussion as
to the date as to when the immigration
white paper will be published seems to
be to be an extraordinary position but
do you accept what the science community
says that access to the best people is
in a sense their most important priority
in these negotiations can you guarantee
that no obstacles will be put in the way
of recruiting the best people from the
EU and indeed from the rest of the world
well I would hope that the science
community would see that the benefit of
moving from would see themselves the
benefit of moving to an immigration
system that is skills based and which is
obviously the but no obstacles in the
way compared to what they have at the
moment because this is really important
for them well I'm not entirely clear
what sort of obstacles you think well if
they have at the moment well if there's
anything else applied to the rest of the
as do to the rest of the world to the EU
there would be enormous obstacles in the
way they need to be able to recruit the
best people without bureaucratic
obstacles placed in the way well there
will always be a process for people to
access so it will be more difficult than
it is at the moment no I didn't say that
sorry because of though that they can
recruit from within the EU without any
obstacles that's going to be more
difficult know that they will be there
will be obviously if we're looking at an
immigration system that is across the
whole of the world and an immigration
system that is skills based then it will
be necessary for there to be a process
for people to go through when they're
recruiting from any somebody from
whatever part of would you see how
important it is for that to be as simple
as possible yes now you've talked about
a far
science and innovation pact and then
subsequently in a court but it's not
referred to specifically in the
political declaration can you confirm
that that's still your intention to
negotiate that far-reaching Accord
because that's really important we are
stemming if you look back to the speech
I first gave in Lancaster House yeah I
think you will see that's when you
entered it but it's not something
political declaration science and
innovation are were one of the areas
where we do want to ensure that we
continue to have that good relationship
now at the time I talked about whether
that is referenced in an accord or
whether it is in some other form that we
ensure that good science that good
relationship is matter but it is one of
the issues that we will be taking
forward can you confirm absolutely that
we will be part of horizon Europe the
funding system that that is well it is I
understand it is possible for third
countries to be part of their rises but
it's the the what the political
declaration makes clear is that we
haven't negotiated the terms on which it
would be possible for the specifics you
can't say now whether we knew be part of
it or not but because this uncertainty
is really damaging they need to know
whether they will be part of this vital
funding system for science what we need
to look at when we come to the legal
texts and the negotiations on the legal
texts is of course the terms on which
being part of that for the United be
possible for the United kill what's the
time long is this going to take whether
those would be within the arrangements
are currently for a third country or
whether those would be different for the
United Kingdom so no no detail on when
this is going to be agreed and whether
we know and when we will know whether we
will be part of horizon Europe that it
will be part of the negotiations that
will be taking place in terms of the
legal text but post the and obviously
there's a there's a there's elements of
preparatory work that will be done
before the 29th of March the legal texts
can't be determined and agreed until
after 29th
now on the European Medicines Agency
Jeremy Hunt when he was health secretary
said that we will continue to work very
closely with the EMA but in the
political declaration all it says is we
will explore the possibility of
cooperation with agencies such as the
EMA much looser can you give any any
indication as to whether it is your
intention
want to do is negotiate a relationship
that ensures that we are able to operate
in relation to the MA in a way that is
suitable for the United Kingdom for the
future visit your miss Phoenicians well
the question is whether or not the MA
does not have third country examples of
membership
unlike eásá which of course does so
there's a model in our piazza which we
believe could be the basis for a model
for the MA but that is that will be part
of the negotiations exactly what that
relationship is whether it is in that
sort of flight third country membership
whether it is some other form of access
in an in legal form that isn't against
the discussion that still has to take
place I mean I think a lot of people
will be worried that on all of this
there seems to be complete uncertainty
with no indication as to when we will
know what the deal will be well the it
was always going to be the case that the
legal texts could not be agreed and
determined until we had left the
European Union and that is the the the
case that was always going to be the
case what we have in the political
declaration is the set of instructions
if you like to the negotiators for the
future to put into place and give effect
to what is in the political declaration
now what I'm saying to you is the
precise form in which that relationship
takes place is one that will be part of
the the the next set of negotiations
good morning Prime Minister and I think
whilst we want to focus primarily on
contingency planning I did want to just
clarify at one point which you've just
referred to in July you told us that you
wanted the UK to continue to participate
in the European Aviation Safety Agency
as a non EU Member State the political
declaration refers only to close
cooperation between the Civil Aviation
Authority and the a sir can you explain
the reason for that discrepancy yes it's
the precise nature and legal form that
will take place that will take for the
cooperation and for our relationship
with the Yasir
is something that will be agreed and
negotiated when the legal text is put
together in the next stage of the
negotiations I say it was always going
to be the case that the legal text would
be negotiated after we left the European
Union the chief executive of the Civil
Aviation or north of n chief executive
the CAA told the Transport Committee in
very emphatic terms that full membership
was the right thing to do if at all
possible so when you have produced the
political declaration did you not listen
to the regulator and the industry or
have the negotiations failed to include
that ambition of full membership for the
UK no the form in which the cooperation
that the CAA will have with you with
Vyasa is one which obviously we've
breathed that that will be a closed
corporation which will ensure high
standards of aviation safety the
question is exactly what the legal
arrangements would be that's a matter
for the next phase of negotiations what
but I think what is important in in a
number of these areas is that we can
either look at this in terms of
maintaining the exact structures that
exist today or maintaining the
capabilities that exist today and
sometimes it's possible to maintain
capabilities but in a different way from
the exact structures that exist today so
I'm not sure that I'm quite clear is it
still your ambition for the UK to be a
full member of er sir as recommended by
everyone in the aviation industry
including the government including the
UK regulator it is it continues to be
our intention to argue for the closest
possible relationship with Piazza now
that would be membership of membership
of the Aza for in the interests of a
security was on and safe aviation safety
what I'm but what I'm saying is that I
think that there will be I'm not saying
this is one of them but there may be a
number of areas the number of areas have
been related referenced that where
membership or a particular relationship
is not identified in the political
declaration but the world the areas
where the question will be how do we
ensure that the capabilities that are
required can be maintained in the future
I think there's a huge difference
between us being members and also having
close cooperation if the chief executive
of the CAA was very clear that if we are
not able to have membership which he
described as a worst case scenario that
we might have to develop her and I asked
the compliant regime but wouldn't that
make us rule takers rather than being a
really important and influential voice
at the table as we are now well we want
to continue to ensure that we are able
to have that influential voice as I say
the legal form that our relationship
takes in the future will be one that has
to be negotiated after we left the EU I
think some of my constituents would like
breaks it to be over and done with
wouldn't they be right to understand
that no matter what happens whatever
happens on the 11th of December it won't
be even if your deal is successfully
ratified by Parliament and that we know
what the mathematics are it is the case
that breaks it will not be over and done
with because there will be at least
another two years of ongoing
negotiations about the answer and a
whole range of other things isn't it
important that the public know that
there will be ongoing negotiations but
we will have left the European Union we
will no longer be a member of the
European Union
because we will cease to be a member of
the European Union on the 29th March
next year I think it's important that I
understand that will not be the even if
that happens that will not be the end of
discussions about brexit because as you
acknowledge there are many many
important matters that are not secure
the negotiations on the legal text of
that future relationship cannot take
place until
no longer a member of the European Union
so we will be continuing to negotiate on
those matters but we will not be a
member of the European Union so we'd be
out without the leverage to negotiate
what we want no we'll be out but we will
be negotiating on the basis of a
political declaration that is set out
clearly what we want apart from in it
doesn't actually say anything about
membership of a very important European
safety agency that has huge implications
for our aviation and aerospace sectors
what it does is recognize that we will
continue to have a relationship in order
to ensure high standards of aviation
security at aviation safety and that's
what I think I think the public will
want to know that we're going to be able
to continue to ensure aviation safety
journey to contingency in July the
National Audit Office said that the
Department for Transport faces a
considerable challenge in preparing for
brexit and yesterday the Public Accounts
Committee said there's a real risk the
Department for Transport won't be ready
in the event of the UK departing the EU
without a negotiated deal why is that
the department the Department for
Transport not ready well the Department
of Transport has been putting a number
of elements of preparation in place it
is one of the departments that has had
legislation going through the house for
example in preparation for these four
these all scenarios but there clip but
we heard that they're not ready how will
you make sure that that department and
indeed all of us are brought back on
track well that the work that the
secretary stated in the European Union
is doing in bringing together the
departments in looking at the priorities
this is looked at constantly both
preparedness for deal proudness for no
deal as I say there have been various
elements of the preparations that have
needed to be put in place including
elements in relation to Parliament I
think we remain concerned that time is
ticking and things are not ready thank
you
pregnant so are you concerned about the
scale of the challenges that will face
the NHS and
and most importantly patience in the
event that we do crash out with no deal
in a no transition in 120 days well I'm
I'm chairman I'm presenting a good deal
to Parliament which I knew that the
Parliament will recognize but I do
understand sorry I just wanted to come
back to that opening than my opening
comments that given the parliamentary
arithmetic it does look increasingly
likely that that we could crash out with
no dealing and given the scale of the
consequences for patients we're looking
at supplies of critical medicines
medical products and devices many areas
where they can't be stockpiled for
example because they have a very short
shelf life complex illogical
there are so many patients that will
face very serious disruption to
essential supplies and medicines that is
that keeping you awake at night I'm
ensuring that the Department Health and
Social Care is obviously doing a lot of
work in this area but I do come back and
they are looking at what is necessary in
worried the circumstances of a No Deal
but of course the way one way to ensure
that we get the good deal and that we
are able to see that smooth and orderly
exit from the European Union when we
leave on the 29th of March next year is
to ratify the deal that the government
is negotiating take you back to the
point that Yvette Cooper made earlier
could any responsible government allow
the scale of chaos that would ensue if
we had no deal and no transition what
could any responsible government allow
that could you allow that I think the
role of a responsible government in
these circumstances is to ensure that
government is prepared for any scenario
that all scenarios that develop and to
ensure that where there are potential
difficulties that those are mitigated to
the greatest extent possible that's the
work that's being done by dexo and by
departments across government in
relation
this issue I guess I accept that
contingency planning is now happening to
try and mitigate it but but would you
accept that there would still be serious
consequences for patients if we were to
leave with no deal and could you allow
that to happen the Department of Health
and Social Care is putting in place
arrangements to ensure that in those
circumstances yes it would still be
possible for people to access the
medicines that are required for
everybody sorry do you accept that that
wouldn't happen for everybody though
Prime Minister even with good
contingency planning which is happening
rather belatedly
that there would be patients that would
be seriously impacted by shortages of
essential supplies of medicines and
devices well the whole point of the work
that the DHS C is doing is to ensure
that those medicines and devices are
available in all circumstances if they
advise you that they won't be and that
you receive advise that that there will
be disruption inspite of careful
planning would you give us your
assurance that you wouldn't allow us to
crash out with No Deal if that would
cause serious disruption to to patients
well the the decision which is going to
be taken on December the 11th by members
of the House of Commons is what it
pertinent in this in relation to this
that decision will be about whether to
accept a deal which is a good deal for
the United Kingdom which enables that
smooth normally because a point that is
little focused on but is relevant
particularly relevant in relation to
these matters is that withdrawal
agreement of course sets up the
implementation period and it is that
implementation period it allows that
orderly exit from the European Union
right but the I'm afraid the the
parliamentary arithmetic is such that it
looks as if that isn't going to pass the
Commons okay can I ask it in your letter
to the nation you refer to the 394
million a week to the NHS could you
confirm for me that that 394 million a
week
would happen whatever happens on the
11th that if we have no brexit or indeed
we have your your future arrangements
would we still have that 394 million a
week the government has made a
commitment to went to the National
Health Service and to the funding of the
National Health Service we set that out
in the budget so in we set that out of
the budget you not true but I am what I
am working for and I think anybody if
any without these matters that this is
another reason for focusing on the deal
it is been the European Union could I
just add to their priminister because my
question to you is would it happen
irrespective of the deal is that is that
promise still in place we have made we
have made that commitment to the
National Health Service but I think in
relation to these are all of the other
matters that you're talking about
chairman this is this is a point of
focus at the on December the 11th when
members of parliament will be so are you
saying today we've made it is this a
threat we lose informant that we won't
that's much I'm not so it'll happen in
irrespective of it that was just my
question it is not I have said we have
made a commitment to the National Health
Service we made that because we believe
it is right for the National Health
Service you've raised a number of other
issues in your questions and I come back
to the point that those are exactly the
sort of issues that members may be
thinking about when they're looking at
the we have a decision on December the
11th whether to deliver on the vote of
the British people in a way that
protects jobs and our economy and
livelihoods and allow the smooth and
orderly exit from the EU or not right so
and just coming back to that led to the
nation you've written to the nation
you're now travelling around the country
and why won't you now ask them if this
is the brexit that they voted for is
this what they meant by brexit the well
I think you're aware
Travon of my position in relation to the
question of the second referendum
Parliament over now and if I made that
there was several aspects to this
Parliament overwhelmingly gave the vote
to the British people as to whether or
not to leave the European
I believe it is a matter of the issue of
the integrity of politicians and
people's trust in politicians that we
actually deliver on that vote and there
are many people who came to democracy
who voted in that election who hadn't
voted before and I think whose views
about democracy would be severely
damaged if they felt that politicians
just said no we didn't like the answer
you gave so why don't you have another
look that's the first the first the
first point I make I think it is
important for our democracy that we
deliver on the vote that people took in
2016 but actually if you if you look at
the practicalities of this issue it is
clear that any second referendum that
would be held if that were the case
would not be able to be held by the by
the 29th of March next year we would be
leaving on the on the 29th of March next
year and so what would what would be the
circumstance in that would have to
extend allow for a referendum yes the
European use of indicators of a paradox
there's a paradox here if you extend
article 50 actually you're then in the
business of renegotiating the deal this
is this is the point the deal the deal
is the deal at this point in time and
people have looked at the deal setting
aside any concerns I have about
extending article 50
actually not delivering on the vote of
the British people that's my fundamental
concern about all these suggestions that
have a second referendum or going back
to the people with a vote in some form
people voted to leave the European Union
it is our duty to deliver that for
people right but my understanding is
that article 50 could be extended to
allow for a referendum on your deal it
wouldn't negate your deal it wouldn't
cancel the deal it would just allow you
to decide which I would allow the people
to give you that their verdict on
whether this is what they meant by
brexit no the
the first of all my point about
democracy still stands I think it's
absolutely important that we deliver on
the vote that people gave having given
overwhelmingly this Parliament gave
people that vote and I really believe
that we should deliver on that but no
any any what is clear is that any
extension to article 50 anything like
that reopens the negotiations reopens
the deal and that at that point the deal
could go frankly in any direction so is
that what you've been explicit what if
one in a minute to other colleagues but
I think that's a really important point
have you been told by the European Union
that you would have to reopen
negotiations were you to hold a
referendum based on your deal to ask the
British this is whether this is what
they meant my brexit is this is what
it's very clear and what has been made
clear is that this is the deal that they
have negotiated with European Union so
with any suggestion of that that deal
might be rejected any I mean I still
come back to the point that actually I
think the most important reason the most
important reason why we should not be
going down the route of a second
referendum is that we ask the British
people they've given us their view and
we should deliver on that view there are
different views as to how we should
deliver on that view but I believe that
we should deliver on it I believe we owe
it to the British people having given
them the choice to actually make that
choice happen for them well I'm afraid
it would be a bit in my view like
wheeling someone into the operating
theatre based on a consent form that
signed - two years ago without renewing
what the operation was and being able to
give proper valid informed consent after
weighing up the risks and benefits of
the actual operation would that not be a
reasonable point well but I think
another point I think if you were to go
down the route we would simply find
ourselves in a period of more
uncertainty and more division in this
country now is the time for this country
to come back together and to look at our
future outside the European Union not to
be encouraging further division well I
must move on coming on next to the
concert
to tional issues and openings opponent
Joe thank you I'm afraid we're going to
need extra five or ten minutes and I
think that's all right I'm afraid so
ultra very quickly I will brevity
indicates no lack of respect to privacy
and just briefly are you aware of a
single pharmaceutical company or
supplier that is not able to assure its
customers that they will receive their
drugs on time if we leave without a deal
I haven't been made aware I don't think
there is they're all assuring their
customers they will get their drugs and
of course the government was severely
criticized after the brexit vote because
there had been no preparation for a
leave vote but that will be two years
and nine months
to 29th of March will the government be
prepared to leave on the 29th of March
without a deal if those are the
circumstances we will be leaving the
European Union on the 29th of March and
the gonna be fully prepared we are and
we are putting preparations in place and
just on the forecasts the Treasury under
George Osborne did produce forecasts
just before the referendum in May 2016
forecasting a collapse in growth and
jobs how accurate were those four costs
well I think we've seen from what has
happened that actually the reaction was
rather different to those forecasts if I
may the analysis that has been put
forward by the government is not a
forecast it is an analysis of the trade
impact yes and what you said was the
economic analysis doesn't deal with the
decisions the government might take
that's correct isn't it yes so basically
they're rubbish are they
well I think there is a there is a
difference of opinion about the benefit
of forecast analysis and so forth the
point is that the analysis only looks at
certain elements it doesn't look at
every variable that can be bought in can
affect what happens to our economy in
the in the future but it is the analysis
that we said we will bring forward to
show the trade impacts of the various
scenarios it's quite something when our
own Chancellor and our own Bank of
England governor trashes the future of
our country as part of a propaganda
exercise that is news that is not what
is happening that is not what it's not
it isn't if I may the Treasury select
committee has made clear that they want
to analysis from the government and
analysis from the Bank of England both
of those have been provided their
different sorts of work the Bank of
England's is a forecast over five years
the which as I said earlier does show
that there would be a deal dividend from
the deal that I've negotiated with the
European Union the government's analysis
is analysis of the trade impact over a
50 looking ahead to 15 years but of
course it doesn't reflect actions other
actions and other variables that would
affect our economy on the question of
cabinet collective responsibility one of
the most contentious bits of the
political declaration is article 23
which states the economic partnership
should build and improve on the single
customs territory provided in the local
agreement
who authorized officials in Brussels to
negotiate on that basis well this is
this is a set of words which have come
to take on a meaning which is not the
the meaning behind those behind those
words the what has happened in relation
to the moloids that my only question is
who authorized the political declaration
was agreed by politicians most at what
time the officials to negotiate those
words well these these were ongoing
negotiations that were taking place
throughout this political declaration
who won't fight until the point at which
it was right until the point at which
was read there was very variations being
made this is this is who
sorry who authorized that well
ultimately I sat down with European
Union leaders and agreed this virtual
recreation Dominic robbers Dex new
secretary subsequently stated that he
only found out about this policy on
Tuesday the 13th of November but the day
before your long cabinet meeting why was
that the well the cabinet came together
on the the next day to look at the text
that had been in preparation over that
whole period of time text was changing
in a variety of ways over that period of
time so it was changed without his
knowledge no I didn't say that well he
said that the this this piece of text is
something that has been assumed to mean
something that it does not because
mattes you can think that's very
important it does matter what this text
means actually the single customs first
of all the single customs territory was
something we were able to achieve in the
negotiations because the European Union
had started off saying that Northern
Ireland should be a separate customs
territory from the rest of from Great
Britain we argued from February to
October that that should not be the case
and we got the agreement on the single
customs territory
what has also main behind that agreement
on the single customs territory is the
divisibility of the four freedoms the
divisibility of the four freedoms or its
indivisibility as the EU would look at
it has been one of the issues it's under
laying the question as to what sort of
trade relationship the United and
Customs relationship the United Kingdom
could have with the European Union in
the film in the future the the fact of
the acceptance of the divisibility of
the four freedoms in that
in discussing issues which are the
responsibility of other ministers
consulting and ministerial colleagues as
appropriate
why was the Dex you secretary not
consulted on this but the DEXA secretary
was consulted was being consulted on an
ongoing basis on text that was being
developed within the within the
negotiations but you depth he was
deputizing for you in these negotiations
and you didn't consult him why isn't
that a breach of the ministerial code
there were the DEXA secretary was being
consulted as were other ministers on an
ongoing basis when this occasion is when
the political declaration was being put
together I think I've made my point
there's a prime minister good morning
there's an urgent question which is
taking place right now actually on the
advice of the Attorney General and the
publication of it and I'm going to be
asking you some questions about that
myself now the prime the ministerial
code states states diseases of paramount
importance that all ministers give
accurate and truthful information to
Parliament correcting in any inadvertent
error at the earliest opportunity and
the knowingly misleading Parliament
leads to resignation I asked you at the
liaison committee on the 18th of July
whether you had asked the law officers
for their opinion on checkers in good
time beforehand as required by the code
and as a critical legal consideration as
it sets out you merely replied that the
law officer sits around the cabinet
table and is thereby consulted which is
clearly not what the code requires yet
again on Monday this week after you had
signed the withdrawal agreement I asked
you a question on your statement how
this being a treaty which is that what
this is and only a treaty it can be
lawfully compatible with the overriding
cetra expressed repeal of the whole of
the European communities act 1972 and
whether you had sought the legal opinion
of the Attorney General on this critical
legal consideration
good time before your signature you did
not reply to that question I asked it
again did you seek his opinion on math
issue and will you publish that advice
as required by the votes on the humble
address and which is directly relevant
to compliance with the code and the full
considered critical consideration that
this legal matter clearly requires by
the Attorney General before your
signature and on the withdrawal
agreement and it's being laid before the
house Wendy well so William you asked me
this question about the fact that we had
repealed in the European Union
withdrawal Act we'd repeal to the whole
of the European communities act 1972 and
that this force therefore incompatible
legally with the withdrawal agreement
and with the political declaration it
was always it has always been the case
that the reason the reason we passed the
European Union withdrawal acts in
relation to the bringing the European
the EU law their key into UK law was to
ensure that we had a working statute
book and when we left the European Union
on the 29th of March 2019 it was always
the case that along side that whatever
the withdrawal agreement required would
be legislated for in Parliament before
the 29th of March 2019 Cobra so that
they would know that there will be no
incompatibility with these two well it
is it is it is up to Parliament whether
it is except the but it was always the
case and it was always made clear that
what whatever was in the withdrawal
agreement would be legislated for by
Parliament and that that legislation
obviously would take account as it would
in the implementation period of the
necessity of making any putting any
position into place to continue to
enable the smooth function of our laws
and the smooth function of that statute
I mean this is a very unusual situation
in that this withdrawal agreement cuts
across an act of Parliament which quite
clearly overrides a treaty and that is
matter of law in the matter of fact what
I do really want you to ask the question
did you enjoy but seek the opinion of
the Attorney General on those questions
and also in relation to the checkers
questions I'm getting no answers to
these questions and you will know that
we do not set out when we do or do not
seek the opinion of the law offices and
we do not publish the full advice of the
law offices and I answer that a point in
earlier this week the we set up we set
out in the white paper legislating for
the withdrawal agreement that the
withdrawal agreement bill will make
amends to the Act to the withdrawal it
European Union withdrawal Act to ensure
it reflects our commitments under the
withdrawal agreement now obviously
Parliament has a job of scrutinizing
those provisions when we bring forward
the bill as it does with all legislation
but it was clear at the time there was a
recognition at the time of the
interaction of the withdrawal act the
repeal of the European communities act
1972 and the legislative requirements of
any future withdrawal agreement it was
set out to Parliament the process that
would take place that related to those
was very clear and I've just sat at this
moment in time the treaty is quite
clearly inconsistent with the withdrawal
act and the thing anyone can dispute
that and it was but we were always clear
that what was necessary in the treaty
what was necessary in the withdrawal
agreement was would be put into place
with the or amendments necessary they
would be put into place with the
withdrawal agreement bill well we don't
have much more time I simply say I just
don't think you'll get that through
Parliament in the withdrawal bill when
it comes up and it's inconsistent with
the existing repeal of the European
community at 970 which is absolutely ex
emetic and absolutely fundamental to our
leaving the European Union well the the
the reason we understood what we did in
the European Union
drawn act was to ensure that we did have
there was no cliff ant in relation to
the laws that were operating that there
was a smooth functioning of our laws and
a statute book when we leave the when we
cease to become a member of the European
Union that was preparatory that was
important to do preparatory work because
for any circumstances of leaving the
European Union it was important to have
that in place I think what what you've
just said to me is that if Parliament
ratifies withdrawal agreement Parliament
won't agree to put in place the
legislative measures necessary to enact
here's the repeal of the European
community at 1972 is so fundamental to
this entire operation this is quite
inconceivable that under the withdrawal
agreements and subsequent legislation
you then modify the European community
at 1972 and reduce the impact of the act
of Parliament that was already passed on
the 26th of June with Royal Assent the
the circumstances in which that is any
amendments are necessary are the
circumstances in which we put into place
the implementation period which is there
to ensure that there is an orderly exit
from the European Union that we have a
transition through to the future
relationship that businesses are able to
continue to operate as they do today
that citizens know where they stand this
is about providing reassurance to
businesses and people across our country
that this process will be as smooth and
orderly one and that they can have that
they can have that reassurance and that
confidence but I think it is entirely
responsible with the Parliament to
recognise we recognize that we're
leaving the European Union there is no
doubt that we're leaving the European
Union the question is how we do that and
if we do that in a way that protects
jobs if we do that in a way that ensures
that we're able to give people who
businesses the reassurance that they
need as they're going through this going
through this process I'm not sure that
many people will be rich
the idea that the european community
said neither 72 he's going to played
around with in that way given the fact
that there is you quite rightly said
that was a decision that was taken on
the referendum vote itself but i think i
have to deposit that i think people will
be will want reassurance of knowing that
there is protection for their jobs that
businesses are able to as we leave the
European Union that there will not be
the disruption that would that people
have said would be the case if we'd not
have that implementation period in that
transition to the future relationship so
we do have to end their prime minister
thank you very much and and I very much
hope this world that you will agree to
come back to this committee should the
vote not pass and we are in uncharted
waters I think we have arrangements for
the number of plants I come to the
committee in in any year portcullis
house the Boothroyd room